[Musique]
généreusement garni doré à point et
surtout croustillante cette année les
galettes frangipan de la maison
Halloween ont été élu meilleur galette
des evelines alors à quelques heures de
l'épiphanie la préparation
s'intensifie bonjour jérô et Jimmy
hallown boulangerie pâtisserie Halloween
à Marle Leroi élu meilleur galet desin
2024 on vous emmène avec nous pour la
fabrique
galettes sacré pour la première fois
cette année les gérants ont mis les
bouché doubles pour faire face à la
demande et tout commence avec une bonne
préparation de la pâte et là sous vos
yeux vous voyez la pâte s'étale
gentiment c'est parti allez c'est
parti donc là on va venir détendre notre
notre pâte voilà le but c'est qu'elle se
repose un petit peu sur plan de travail
qui est
réfrigéré
voilà voilà comme ça elle se détend un
petit peu ça va nous permettre de
détailler les abaisses bien rondes afin
d'éviter et que les galettes ovalisent
par la suite à la cuisson une fois
étalée la pâte est découpée elle sera
ensuite placée au frais pour 24 he après
ça place à la garniture à base de crème
d'amande et de crème pâtissière
quasiment l'une et dernière étape on
vient poser délicatement le dessus de la
galette étape du chiquetage c'est ce qui
va nous permettre de bien souder le
dessus et le dessous ensemble afin que
la crème franipane ne s'échappe pas au
four pour donner toute sa brillance à la
galette elle est ensuite recouverte
d'une préparation aux œufs elle sera une
nouvelle fois placée au frais pour
plusieurs heures dernière étape avant la
cuisson le rayage il a plus qu'à mettre
au
[Musique]
fond et donc maintenant place à la
dégustation voilà on va couper notre
galette
ça le résultat après la la fabrication
vous voyez bien garni et c'est notamment
grâce à cette garniture que la
boulangerie pâtisserie a réussi à faire
la différence remportant deux titres
pour ces galettes on a quand même cuit
une vingtaine de galettes pour sortir
vraiment les les plus parfaites les
critères de notation étent la cuisson la
garniture la décoration voilà donc on a
fait attention à tous les aspect que ça
soit notre rayage voilà un beau sirop
pour faire briller la galette également
grâce à cette récompense les ventes
devrai augmenter de 50 % malgré son
succès le prix reste inchangé compteter
5 € la part pour savourer la championn
des galettes siblinoises